hey how you doing this is Mel strong and
this is a lecture on air pressure and
wind now we've talked about air pressure
in the previous lecture and what we said
is we looked at an animation like this
and we talked about how air molecules
fly in a straight line till they collide
with something so they quite with each
other or they collide with surfaces so
every surface that's exposed to the
atmosphere is being hit by air molecules
billions of times a second and that
produces a pressure now the earth is
trying to pull all the air down to the
ground and it can't get it all down
there but what it does do is it
increases the amount of air that's
closer to the surface which increases
the air pressure that's closer to the
surface as you go up into the atmosphere
there's less air molecules flying around
so there's less air pressure so we have
some units that we use to describe air
pressure and one of them is maybe this
is the one that's familiar to you it's
psi pounds per square inch it's the
easiest one to visualize so imagine one
inch by one inch square so if I have 15
psi that means I got 15 pounds pushing
down on each square
okay now psi we use in tires so the if
you look on site of your tires will have
a PSI rating or inflatable toys or balls
or whatever that kind of thing they will
have psi ratings well the atmosphere
could be measured in psi and so if you
go to the sea sea level the air pressure
is pretty close to 15 pounds per square
inch so think about what that means that
means if you're standing at the ocean
for every square inch on your body
you've got 15 pounds pushing so the
question is why don't we notice this
right so if I take my hand anything well
okay how many square inches could you
draw on your hand so I don't know let's
just say six okay I can draw six square
inches on my hand right so if I hold it
out that means I have 15 pounds roughly
on every one of those
six square inches less ninety pounds so
how is it possible I can just do this
right it's like it's no big deal
and I really don't feel anything
so the answer this think about what it's
like to be in deep water see if you've
ever died of deep let's say you go down
to the deep end of a pool let's say you
had somebody that you could like sit on
the bottom of the deep end of the pool
what you would notice is that the air or
sorry the water pressure is confining
you from all directions but all the
water was above your head so in other
words you don't feel the the water from
the swimming pool pushing down on your
head only it's all around you it's a
fluid well the atmosphere is also a
fluid and it behaves in a similar way so
I hold my hand out yes I have
whatever was ninety pounds pushing down
but I also have ninety pounds pushing up
and those two forces cancel each other
out and I don't notice a thing so this
is the thing that kind of takes a little
bit getting used to all the atmospheres
above my hand right it's all above my
all the atmospheres up there but the
force pushing down from above is the
same as the force pushing up from below
that's the nature of a fluid okay so
most of the time we don't notice air
pressure unless there's some weird
imbalance of it now psi use four tires
on toys but turns out we generally don't
use it for weather okay we have a couple
other ones that we use instead now to
get to some of the new or the other
units that we use so as you know if you
have a fluid and you have a straw and
you create a vacuum right you suck air
out of the straw that liquid will go up
the straw right and then you've probably
done thing we suck on a little bit and
put your thumb over it and it'll stay
there right because you've made a vacuum
in here you've made there's less air
pressure in here and that will suck up
the liquid right okay well
for many years engineers are trying to
figure out how do we get water up a
multi-story building right so this was
years before electricity and they were
trying to figure out if we had it we if
we had a cistern sitting down here water
tank couldn't we put like a really tall
pipe in suck it up right couldn't we do
that so they tried this and it turns out
that no matter how hard you try you
cannot suck water up more than about 34
feet from where it originated from and
it doesn't matter you could have a
thousand people all sucking on this
straw and it will not go beyond 34 feet
of course they weren't actually using
humans to suck they were trying to make
a machine that would act as a vacuum
pump that would suck the water out and
they found well that's weird doesn't
matter what we do we just can't get
beyond 34 feet now this was a this
problem had been known for a while but
here's a weird thing when they did this
and not only did it stay if it's 34 feet
mark but they also noticed that the
exact level kind of changed a little bit
with the weather and so if it was sunny
clear day it seemed to be a little bit
higher and if it was a cloudy rainy day
it seemed to be a little bit lower so
they lost that's kind of weird now this
was a problem that had vexed people for
a long long time because one of the
biggest problems that still actually
faces miners today but especially in the
ancient times is if you dig a deep
underground mine it can easily get
filled with water right groundwater
comes in here and that's a problem
because you're trying to dig out the ore
but it keeps filling up with water so
for a long time like hundreds of years
people have been trying to figure out
how do you get water up out of the hole
and so they've been trying different
vacuum techniques to do this so 1600s
torch Shelley was a scientist and he was
trying to figure this out you know why
is this the
four-foot women why does this happen and
as he was messing around with this he
figured out that you know you know it's
difficult to have a 34-foot pipe with
water in it to experiment in the lab but
what you could do is even if you had a
denser liquid you could kind of shrink
the whole thing down and so he found the
densest liquid he could find which is
mercury and he found out that if you
took mercury and he filled up a tube
that's closed on one end and he tipped
it upside down and he put it into a bowl
of mercury and he let his thumb off that
the mercury would fall down a certain
amount okay and now at the time they
didn't understand anything about air or
air pressure they think arum or had any
pressure and he didn't know what a
vacuum was but this little experiment
proved that actually you can make a
vacuum there's no way air could have
gotten into this little hole and let me
just point out that scientists were
balling back there look at that look at
that outfit I wish we were still wearing
that today so Tortelli fills this tube
with mercury dish with mercury says his
buddies got the earth through there's
liquid mercury sitting in this bowl and
he's holding this glass tube here and
what happens is the atmospheric pressure
pushes down on the surface of mercury
pushes it up the tube to a certain level
okay so this was the first time that
anybody realized that the atmosphere
actually has pressure now the other
thing that he noticed just like the guys
that were trying to suck water up to the
top of the building is that the height
of this would change a little bit with
the weather so I got sunny this little
column of mercury got a little bit
higher and it was cloudy he got a little
bit less and the really weird thing is
it seemed to be able to predict the
weather so if he saw it starting to
climb then he knew it's going to be
sunny weather and if it started to fall
started to go down he knew it's going to
be stormy weather now this freaked a lot
of people out and and Tortelli is
temper with Galileo these two guys knew
each other and they are experimenting
with this in total secret because they
figured out anybody saw this they'd be
accused of witchcraft it was freaking
them out too like they couldn't figure
out how in the world can this thing
predict the weather but it seemed to be
able to do it and so what he had
inverting Lee invented in this
experimentation was something that we
now call the barometer and the barometer
works at least the version he made is so
here's the Tortelli barometer he got a
pool mercury and you got the tube
atmospheric pushes down pushes it up the
tube and you have this column and so the
way they would measure the air pressure
is that they would measure the height of
this column from down here so if the air
pressure increases that more mercury
gets shoved up the tube if the air
pressure decreases less mercury gets
shoved up the tube and the column Falls
and so what do they do they measure this
distance in inches or in millimeters so
a unit of air pressure became inches of
mercury or millimeters of mercury and
that was just this height that's what
that was the the unit that they've
figured out now over time people dropped
the words of mercury so it became
millimeters or it became inches so an
air pressure reading might say 30
point-0 six inches and that you just
have to know that's what they're talking
about they're talking about inches of
mercury in this barometer well the
problem with this setup as I've showed
you you know if I torch all we didn't
know this but you never want to touch
mercury okay it's extremely poisonous if
it touches your skin that's bad news but
even like in this instrument these got
there's a there's open mercury in this
bowl and mercury actually evaporates and
mercury vapors are extremely poisonous
to cause brain cancer all kinds of
trouble so an actual mercury barometer
this is what one looks like and they've
got it all kind of covered in glass too
the mercury vapors to come out but it's
not something you want in your house and
so over time people figured out other
ways to do this otherwise to measure air
pressure and today we don't use mercury
we don't have columns of mercury but we
still use the Union inches so here's a
more modern barometer and it says inches
right there and then you can see the
numbers 29 30 31
so this dial tells you how many inches a
mercury barometer would be if you had
one right but nobody uses them anymore
so this inches is a as a holdover from
an ancient time that you know we don't
use mercury barometers we haven't used
them for over a hundred years and you
find one in the museum maybe but that's
it so a more modern unit that we use
besides inches is something called
millibars and sometimes that's
abbreviated mb or sometimes it's
abbreviated as mb AR and then there's
another one that's called hectopascals
HPA
and this gets really confusing I don't
want to get too deep into this a
millibar and a hectopascal are the same
thing they're just different units in
this class we're going to I'm just going
to be using the word millibar so in this
in this barometer right here says mbar
and you see the numbers that go from 950
all the way around to 1070 right the
ones on the outside so those are
millibars it's very difficult to
visualize a middle bar and it's a
mathematical thing we're not going to
get into it so all I'm gonna say is that
at sea level there's about a thousand
thirteen middle bars
okay and that's going to have to do for
this class because we can't get into
exactly what a middle bar is so here's
another barometer this is using using HP
a hectopascals which again for this
class it's the same thing as a middle
bar okay just another way of writing it
and again you see the numbers are in the
nine hundreds to the low thousands
so because air pressure varies with
Heights we could write out what the air
pressures would be at some different
locations on earth so at sea level so
you for a San Francisco like we already
said it's about 14.7 PSI turns out
that's pretty close to 30 inches of
mercury if you're using the Tortelli
barometer in millibars that's a thousand
thirteen okay so as you go up up to
albuquerque our pressure is about twelve
psi which is about twenty four and a
half or so inches of mercury and about
eight hundred and thirty-four millibars
you get to the top of Sandia Crest
you're below 10 inches of sorry well 10
psi you're 20 inches of mercury 678
millibars if you want all the way that
the top of Mount Everest at 30,000 feet
or so it's about four and a half PSI in
your less than 10 inches of mercury and
300 millibars so as you go up no matter
how you measure the amount of air
pressure decreases now the thing is we
see these big changes in the air
pressure from elevation and that's true
but that's not actually what we're
interested in what we're interested in
is that these values actually change a
little bit with the weather so this is
what we're talking about with Tortelli
and galileo looking at that we'll call
moving up and down like it's telling us
something about the atmosphere so these
numbers are average values so in
albuquerque or average values 834
millibars but it goes up a few more bars
it goes down a few millibars and that's
what we're interested in is that little
change so why would it change well if
you want if you remember way back in the
lecture on clouds we talked about how
the atmosphere is divided into two parts
that we talked about the troposphere in
the stratosphere winds that are way up
in the upper part of the troposphere up
by what we called the tropopause if you
remember that they sometimes come
together and converge and if they do it
turns out that air when it crashes into
each other for reasons we haven't really
got into yet but what we
later it can't really go up into the
stratosphere instead it goes down so
when winds up here converge and when
this word aloft that just means up above
our heads winds aloft are the winds up
up there when they converge that forces
air to go down well when you force air
to go down it compresses and when you
compress air at worm's well what happens
when you have a column of compressing
warming air well that air is very
difficult to form clouds in remember for
clouds we want air to rise and this air
is sinking it's going the wrong way and
it's getting warmer and we need air to
get cooler so cloud formation is very
unlikely and if you remember from the
convection lecture we talked about
stable and unstable air
this makes stable air so all of this is
to say that when this whole thing you
know when these winds off converge all
these things happen and you as a person
on the ground
notice that the air pressure has
increased so if you get the Tortelli
barometer when this is happening up here
the the column of mercury is rising and
so there's a they talk about the
barometer rising that means that column
is going up even though we don't use
mercury today we still use that term the
barometer is rising when this process is
happening now on a map what we would do
is we would draw a big H on the map to
represent the center of high pressure
now in my drawing here this looks really
small that's misleading this process
this thing is calm air it's going to be
the size of several states big States
I'll show you that in a little bit now
maybe the winds aloft will diverge so
this is the opposite so instead of
moving together on a collision course
they tend to diverge apart from each
other and that essentially kind of
creates a vacuum there's a lack of air
here and so what happens is air rises up
from the surface to replace the vacuum
that's being created well whenever air
rises it expands and expanding air cools
and what we've said before
is that that's what you need to make
clouds right you want air to rise
expands it cools you hit the dew point
you get a cloud this is what contributes
to unstable air okay so whenever you
have this whole process of winds
diverging aloft air is rising you're
making clouds are making unstable air
and it's kind of like a giant vacuum
cleaner above your head that's sucking
air up away from you you will notice
that the air pressure down here
decreases now it's not like there's a
literal wind flying up from the ground
it's much more subtle than that but if
you got one of those barometers you'll
notice that the air pressure is going
down when this process is happening and
so on a weather map will put a big L to
represent a lower center of low pressure
and again this process is much larger
than this diagram implies so on a
weather map we will plot HS and LS to
kind of look like this so from this we
know several things now how would you
predict the weather say right here in
Colorado well there's a low there so we
know the air is rising we know rising
air is conducive to cloud formation so
it's probably cloudy here we don't have
enough information to know if it's
raining or not but we have a pretty good
chance that the Daley's to have cloudy
skies okay what's the air here doing the
air here is sinking so what's their
weather like probably clear skies
sinking air the air sinking warming and
it's making stable air you can't really
make convection so they probably have
clear skies now there is a couple other
ways besides the two I just talked about
to make highs and lows if you have
somewhere that's really warm and warm
air rises so here we are out in the
tropics and we've got poems of warm air
rising from the ocean going up and
making you know cumulonimbus clouds then
as you bring air up off the surface you
are lowering the pressure at the surface
and this is called a thermal low so
places are really hot like Arizona in
the summer we'll have thermal
so this is a different way to make a
low-pressure anytime you have air that's
rising from heat or convection you will
get a low at the surface and then
there's also another way to make a
high-pressure and you can get this and
really really cold places so if you have
a blob of really cold air that comes in
over the continent in a classic example
of Siberia right you're up in northern
Russia and there's really cold lava air
comes down and settles over the land
really cold air contracts and as it
contracts in shrinks more air kind of
fills in above it and what happens from
that is the person that's sitting down
on the ground in that really cold air
will notice the air pressure goes up
you're kind of like piling more and more
air on the surface and because it
shrinks when it's cold it'll let you
pile more on top and pretty soon you got
a high pressure at the surface so this
is sometimes called a cold high or cold
core high now we can look for some of
these features so here I am at the web
site we've been to before earth nil
Schoolnet and so by default that's
showing you wind and what I'm gonna do
is click the word earth and hang on the
click on MSL P and that's for mean sea
level pressure and this is going to show
us
air pressure along the earth now here's
the scale the colors the widest white
colors are the highest air pressure and
then well rare pressure is is the yellow
and then the really low pressure gets
into blue and then even lower than that
enter into red ok so let's look around
here now as we look around we can see
like for example here's this big purple
blob this is an area of low pressure so
that tells us air here must be rising
okay air here must be rising and if I
look at the United States today I see
that whitish color right there so that's
high pressure so we know that air must
be sinking right there
okay so all every purple blob you see is
a place where air is rising every white
blob you see like here's a big one out
in the ocean where air is sinking okay
now I'm going to change the overlay to
temp for temperature and this is surface
temperature okay so now the colors mean
temperature I want to go over here to
our friends in Siberia and notice how
yet this is a big blob a ruby cold air
that's sitting over the continent right
now so that purple that's really cold
air that's coming down from the North
Pole alright I'm going to switch it to
MS LP again for sea level pressure you
notice that this whole blob is now white
that is that tells us that's high
pressure this is an example of a cold
core hi so this is a high pressure due
to really cold air that sunk down again
from the North Pole and it settles over
the Asian continent or we go down to the
equator and notice that I've got some
dark purple there but I also kind of
have a general purple hue all the way
across here see that right through there
so that is a thermal low right through
in the middle of the Equator it's so
warm and it's so humid you have constant
cumulonimbus in this area every day and
that means air is rising and that
creates a low pressure at the surface
this is a thermal low kind of right
through there we see again over here
kind of goes through Central Africa it's
pretty close to the equator right there
is the equator right so it's kind of
around there and then over here kind of
does something different so that is a
thermal low this was a cold core high
and then each one of these little blobs
there's something happening in the
atmosphere where we got air converging
or diverging aloft which is either
making air rise or sink in the
atmosphere so what air pressure were
interested in the changes due to weather
but the problem is the changes due to
elevation are far far greater so imagine
we've got three cities here at San
Francisco Albuquerque
in Leadville Colorado and San Francisco
being at sea level is going to average a
thousand thirteen millibars plus or
minus a few millibars with the weather
but we are going to be like 834
millibars plus or minus a few and
Leadville Colorado being a thousand over
ten thousand feet up it's going to be at
six ninety two plus or minus a few so
here's the problem no matter what
happens to San Francisco's weather they
will never ever get air pressure as low
as ours and no matter what happens to
our weather we'll never get an air
pressure as high as theirs
so it's really hard to compare numbers
because we're all at different
elevations so how do we resolve this
well one solution would be well what if
we had everybody on the continent drill
down to sea level right they just
drilled a deep hole and they put the
barometer at the bottom of the hole
right then everybody's got a barometer
at sea level okay then we could compare
numbers that would work but it would be
kind of hard to pull off so what we do
instead is we can actually
mathematically correct for elevation now
we're not going to do that in this class
we're not going to do the math someone
else is going to do that for us but the
convention when we talk about air
pressure and this is kind of a worldwide
convention is we report the air pressure
as if we were at sea level so what
happens is they take a pressure reading
say at the Albuquerque Airport and they
calculate okay what would it be at sea
level if we were at sea level and they
mathematically subtract out the effect
for our elevation and that's the number
that gets reported so when you check the
weather so here I'm at weather.gov this
is where your tax dollars go to for the
best possible weather prediction they're
way better than any kind of other
weather service out there and you look
at so so if you go there you go click to
wherever you live in here I'm at
Albuquerque's Airport and so here's a
reading so as things on here we know now
right humidity is 29% okay what humanity
is
that well because it's a number between
zero and a hundred percent I know that
has to be relative humidity right
there's our dew point so we've talked
about that notice this so here's
barometer thirty point zero eight inches
and then the parentheses a thousand
fifteen point five Nilla
so thirty point zero eight inches means
that if we were at sea level which were
not and if we had an old mercury
barometer which we don't and we set it
up this is what we would measure that
thirty point zero eight inches of
mercury and then in a more modern unit a
thousand fifteen point five millimeter
value valid if we drill down to sea
level here at Albuquerque that's what
the air pressure would be so that's how
it's reported so we call this sea level
pressure right and everybody reports
their barometers as sea level pressure
so after thousands of air pressure
measurements are taking from thousands
of weather stations all across North
America and we mathematically correct
each of those for elevation then we plot
the results on the map that kind of
looks like this this is called a
sea-level pressure map and a sea level
level pressure map so before we continue
if you're one of my current students I
have this posted on learn there's three
pages you might want to print these out
before we start if you're coming here
from somewhere else on the internet I
have these on my website if you want to
download those so there are three pages
and numbered one two three we're going
to start with page number one know the
bottom it says sea-level pressure map
for one 116 okay so first thing is that
there are these numbers ten twenty ten
twenty five 10:30 10:35 those are sea
level pressure contours so these are
contour lines and the way you would read
this is that if you were to walk right
along this line on this day in you're at
sea level which are not but if you were
that the air pressure would be ten
thirty millibars all these are in
millibars they don't say that now each
these contours is the same way if you
walk along these contours you will be
exactly at that pressure indicated by
the number and as long as you stay at
along that line and if you're at sea
level that's what the air pressure would
be so if I were to walk say this way
okay start in southern Texas I walk
north what I would notice is that the
air pressure is increasing 10:25 10:30
10:35 10:40 right or if I start up here
in the North 10 15 20 25 30 35 40 there
increasing towards the center of this
big blob here and in fact right in the
middle this is the highest pressure of
the whole region this 1040 contour so no
matter which way I go air pressure is
increasing towards this region so I'm
gonna put a big H right here for a
center of high pressure okay now what
that means is that this whole blob is a
blob of sinking air okay so to relate it
to something we talked about a few
minutes ago I had a diagram of a person
standing on the ground and air is
sinking above their head and I said at
the time that it's much bigger than this
diagram would have you believe this is
what I mean this thing is huge right it
covers all of the western United States
and parts of Canada this is a big blob
of sinking air so there's air coming
down from the upper part of the
atmosphere squishing out here so we
could say a few things about their
weather right now high pressure that
probably clear skies right it's stable
air we know that another thing that we
can tell from this on this map notice
how if I look at this part I have if I
were to walk this direction the numbers
increase so 10 15 20 25 30 35 and then
if I walk this direction the numbers
decrease okay so it's analogous
to a mountain on the topographic map so
topographic map would have contours
except they mean elevation I'd be
walking up the hill and then be walking
down the hill okay so on a topographic
map this feature right here would be a
ridge this is not topographic map it's
air pressure but we still call it a
ridge it's called a ridge of high
pressure and I just bring this up
because this term ridge ridge of high
pressure is used in meteorology and in
weather reports you might hear it use
something like this though it might say
there's a ridge of high pressure
building over the Four Corners area over
the next several days
what does that mean that means that
there's a high pressure center high
pressure system centered over the Four
Corners area and it's getting stronger
and stronger for the next several days
so when you hear ridge just think high
pressure so even on a map that you know
like this one even if you don't really
see this particular feature it doesn't
matter a ridge is just a blob of high
pressure it's a big blob of sinking air
okay let's go to the second page so
[Applause]
here's the second page and it says
sea-level pressure may have to 25 16 all
right so let's start on the in the West
and we see 10 17 20 22 25 27 30 numbers
a getting larger towards this blob here
or if I go from the south 25 27 30
they're getting larger towards this blob
so locally this is a higher pressure
than anything else so I'm gonna put an H
here okay
now let's look over here
and we've got this weird bullseye
pattern and I've got numbers 10 17 12 10
7 5 2 0 9 9 7 5 they're getting lower
towards the center of this bullseye
pattern or if I go from this direction
they're getting lower towards the center
so if I walk towards the
center of this bullseye pressure is
going down so this is a center of low
pressure and I put my L right in the
center of that thing right there so we
have in the country on this particular
day we have a blob of air that's sinking
down squishing out on the ground on this
part making high pressure and then we
have the blob of air that's rising up
and so we can say a few things about the
weather right we can say that well over
here they probably have clear skies
stable air over here they've got
definitely cloudy in effect this is a
pretty severe storm system here and I
say that because there's so many of
these pressure contour lines pretty
close together this is a pretty strong
storm so all we can gather from what
we've talked about so far is that this
is rising air this is sinking air here
is probably cloudy here is probably
clear beyond that we don't have enough
information yet to say more whether it's
raining or anything like that okay let's
move on to number three okay so the
first thing I'm going to do is identify
highs and lows and so if I look over
here to the east I see thousand twelve
thousand ten thousand seven thousand
five thousand two and there was a
getting smaller towards that bull's eye
so that is going to be low here now our
highs are not as quickly defined there's
one over here and the numbers are kind
of cut off so it's a little hard to see
but ten thousand I'm sorry thousand
seventeen thousand twenty it's cut off
thousand twenty two point five but
that's a high over there I'm just going
to put that on there out of there over
the ocean there's a kind of a small high
over Mexico so this is thousand
seventeen and a half thousand twenty
that one doesn't have a number but
there's our high right here there's
another little high sitting kind of over
the Four Corners area so this thousand
twenty is
bigger than anything around it so
there's a high okay now the reason I
have this map is because I want you to
pay attention to what's happening kind
of in the middle here of the country
these numbers 17 15 12 and a half 1075 -
so these numbers are decreasing towards
the north okay the pressures are
decreasing towards this blob up here
this up here is a low and we actually
the map has been cut off so that we
don't actually see you know these
contour lines don't wrap around there
they're there somewhere up here in
Canada but we don't see them because
this is where the map ends but notice
that in our country how you've got these
u shapes right these u shapes come down
and kind of like we were talking about a
ridge this thing if this is a
topographic map would be a trough if I
walk if this was elevation and I was
walking across here I'd be going down
down down down down and then up up up up
back out of it so this would be like a
valley or a ditch so this thing on a
weather map is called a trough and a
trough is connected as these u shapes
that are connected to a low so the the
center of the low may not even where I
drew it may be similar to the North here
as it's off the map but that's pretty
common so a lot of times where we live
for example our weather map may be cut
off like this and that's all we see and
we don't know what's above here but we
see that we have these u shapes and we
see that the numbers are getting smaller
towards the middle
that's called it a trough of low
pressure so kind of like Ridge it means
high pressure in weather speak trough
means low pressure so when you hear
weather report and they talk about a
trough of low pressure moving across
the country what they are saying is that
there is a little pressure center that's
moving across the country the center of
the low may not be in the country in our
country itself it may be to the north
but it still has the same effect as the
low so this trough as it moves across
the United States air is rising in the
trough so you've got cloud formation in
the trough so in your mind when you hear
trough or trough of low pressure just
think it's a low it's a low pressure
center moving across the country okay so
now we're going to return to Earth Knoll
Schoolnet and I'm looking again mean sea
level pressure I did that by clicking
earth and MSL P so the purple is low
pressure
the white is high pressure and I'm going
to zoom in here and the spot out in the
ocean that's that's a high and I want
you to notice what the winds are doing
so the winds are spinning around in a
circle right and they're going clockwise
now right next to it is this low
pressure this blob and notice that the
winds are spinning counterclockwise
here's another little purple blob
another low pressure winds are spinning
counterclockwise and that's the pattern
that you'll notice here let's find
another one here's another high out in
the ocean clockwise here's another big
low will pressure this was a little
harder to see but overall it's going
counterclockwise alright now this
pattern is consistent throughout the
northern hemisphere if I have a high I
have air circulating clockwise if I have
a low of air circulating
counterclockwise you know go down here
let's see what's happening in the
southern hemisphere so in the southern
hemisphere I've got a bunch of little
pressure centers down here by Antarctica
but notice this low spinning clockwise
here's a low clockwise here's a low
clockwise that's the opposite of what we
just saw or over here here's a high that
white spot counterclockwise so there is
a rule regarding the winds around highs
and lows but it depends on what
hemisphere you're in so if you're in the
southern hemisphere wind goes
counterclockwise around a high and
clockwise around a low if you're in the
northern hemisphere it goes clockwise
around a high counterclockwise around a
low okay so why is this well this has to
do with the famous Coriolis effect so to
explain the Coriolis effect let's
consider what would happen if the earth
did not spin if the earth did not spin
then air would want to move directly
from a high to a low in a straight line
okay so any winds that we would have
would be directly between highs and lows
but that's not what we observe on earth
what we observe is that winds in the
northern hemisphere are deflected to the
right so the winds trying to move from
high to low but it can't ever get there
because it's always being moved to the
right it ends up going in a big circle
around the high in a clockwise fashion
in the northern hemisphere or
counterclockwise in the southern
hemisphere so they try to explain this I
have one little demo here and what we're
looking at so imagine this is the earth
and we're looking straight down the
North Pole right so if I have wind
that's moving from the North Pole to the
equator in the earth did not spin wind
is trying to move in a straight line
like this right okay but now let's
imagine that the earth is spinning and
the earth spins counterclockwise on as
you look from the from the perspective
of the North Pole right so now if I move
my my wind in a straight line kind of
clumsy but what I see is that my wind
when the winds perspective is moving as
making a big right-hand turn right it
turned to the right and that was simply
due to the fact that the earth is
spinning so I was trying to hold a
straight line as I was turning that so
that's one demonstration of the Coriolis
effect I've got a couple videos here
that I will also show you the Coriolis
force is an apparent force that causes
moving objects to appear to bend away
from their intended paths this force can
be due to a rotating earth or in this
example a rotating platform on a non
rotating platform we can see that a
thrown ball moves in a straight path to
the receiver suppose the platform begins
to rotate counterclockwise just as the
earth rotates counterclockwise when
viewed from above the North Pole on the
screen to the left we see that the
thrown ball moves in a straight line
path however when we view the thrown
ball on the rotating platform the screen
on the right the camera reveals that
because the platform is rotating the
ball in flight appears to curve to its
right and the receiver has to lean to
the side in order to attempt to catch it
even though the ball actually moves in a
straight line people sitting on the
rotating platform see the ball appeared
to bend to the right of its intended
path the apparent bending of the thrown
ball is due to the fact that the
platform is rotating the apparent force
that causes the bending is the Coriolis
force
so this animation explains Coriolis
effect in a little bit different way and
I think it's great except the graphics
aren't necessarily the highest
resolution but we start out we've got
two points that are on the same
longitude at different latitudes and so
the point is that as the Earth rotates
these two points are going to rotate
together right but if you look at the
paths of each of these two parcels
they're going to be different that the
parcel that was closer to the equator
with a lower latitude had to travel
farther in the same amount of time so it
had to be moving faster so now imagine
that you've got a rocket at the equator
and you're gonna shoot it straight at
this red dot okay but because the rocket
is at a lower latitude it has a higher
easterly velocity so it's moving to the
east faster than this red dot is for the
reasons we just saw so if you shoot the
rocket in a straight line it appears
that it turned to the right but from the
Rockets perspective it was going in a
straight line the whole time it just had
more easterly momentum than the red dot
does and it appears to curve off to the
right then you can think of the opposite
case now imagine the rocket is at the
North Pole ending in the chute it's
straight at this red dot okay but now
the red dot at a lower latitude has a
higher velocity to the east and the
rocket doesn't have any so again it
misses and from the perspective of the
rocket it's going in a straight line but
the perspective of someone on the ground
looking at this it looks like it went
too far to the right so no matter which
way you go in the northern hemisphere if
you move it in a straight line you're
actually being deflected to the right
from the perspective of the person on
the ground that's what the Coriolis
effect is and the Coriolis effect only
works on something that's a very very
long distance so there's a lot of
folklore and urban legend about Coriolis
effect so common one is that toilets
flush clockwise in the Northern
Hemisphere and counterclockwise in the
southern hemisphere maybes opposite
corylus effect only effects things are
very very very long distance so you can
make a toilet flush either way and
either hemisphere it doesn't doesn't
change it if that was true if the
Coriolis effect was so strong that it
would rotate water that only moved a few
inches it would basically be impossible
for us to like drive cars we've just go
flying off the road to the right or even
if you just started to run you just
everybody flying off to the right all
the time so it doesn't happen that way
it just works on things that are out
very long distances so let's return now
to our those three handouts that we were
looking at earlier so these again these
sea level pressure maps in so now what
we can do is we can make predictions
about the direction of the wind so we
the first one we looked at this is map
number one high pressure this big blob
here I know now that winds travel
clockwise around a high so I know that
around this high I don't have winds that
are moving in a clockwise fashion now in
this class what we're going to do is
we're going to assume that the winds are
traveling parallel to the contour lines
so in other words I know the winds going
to be doing this so I'm drawing lines
that are parallel between these contours
but their overall going in a clockwise
fashion right so if I asked you okay
what is the wind well let's say in
Albuquerque what's the wind albuquerque
doing well right here if you drew an
arrow the wind is coming from the
southeast and it's traveling to the
northwest so here's a convention with
wind wind is always described in the
direction is coming from so if I have a
north wind that means it's coming from
the north right if I have a westerly
wind is coming from the West
okay so we can predict which way the
winds going to be blowing by simply
thinking about okay do I have clockwise
or counterclockwise and then drawing a
little short segments that are going
clockwise in this case around this high
but staying parallel to these contour
lines so let's do another example
let's do page two
so we've got wind that's going clockwise
around the high and let's look at the
low instead we've got so we know wind
goes counterclockwise are on the low and
again we're gonna say it goes parallel
to the contour lines so when we be going
kind of like this I'm drawing little
segments right little segments of arrows
that are going over all counterclockwise
but staying between
the contour lines now realistically what
happens is that air that's aloft up
above our heads is moving exactly
parallel to the contour lines just like
I described what happens here on the
ground is a little different wind hits
trees and buildings and mountains and
the slows down and what happens actually
is it spirals inward kind of like this
when it gets close to the surface
showing up or not spiraling inwards and
a near the surface high pressure spirals
outwards near the surface like that but
for this class for the exercises we're
going to do we're just going to draw the
wind arrows parallel to the contour
lines every time okay that way we'll
just be consistent on the wind direction
alright so here's an example what I
could do I can say all right what is the
wind direction in Tennessee
okay so there's Tennessee and we know we
have counterclockwise so it's coming
around this way so what would the wind
be like right there
okay so right there I'm going to draw a
straight segment that is parallel to
those contour lines and it's coming from
the North West right that is a northwest
wind okay so if you're one of my
students you will have an exercise where
you're going to be asked to identify the
wind direction on a map like this so the
correct answer is you want to give or
something like
north or northwest sometimes I get
answers hot wise or counter clockwise so
we never go outside and say oh man is
blowing counterclockwise out here from
our perspective on the ground the wind's
coming from one direction only and what
I'm asking you is to figure out what
that one direction is so you're drawing
your wind direction as straight segments
okay so let's do another one what is the
wind like in Minnesota all right so
here's Minnesota and so here I'm between
a high and I'm between a low so how do I
know which one to pick
so we'll do an example with each so
let's say I do the one with the high I
know I got clockwise around high so I
know I've got wind coming around here
this is going this way so I want to draw
a straight segment in Minnesota so right
there would be the wind direction right
so that's consistent with clockwise
around a high it's coming from the north
to Northeast right okay so let's say
instead I picked the low low
counterclockwise around the low so I've
got wind coming around this way and when
I get down here the Minnesota I'm gonna
have draw a straight segment that's
approximately almost going the exact
same direction as the first one we did
also from the north or a little bit
north east so it doesn't matter which
one you pick you should get the same
answer let's move on to number three so
how would we deal with this trough so in
a low let's look at this little out in
the ocean first you got counterclockwise
around the low so I can draw a little
straight segments around the low like
this right and it's no different around
the low up here the low up here you get
straight segments coming down and going
around that low and counterclockwise
and you just extend that all the way
down so down here in this trough I would
have wind doing this right so I could do
the same thing I could ask you what's
the wind direction at any location here
within the trough now let me go I'm
gonna pull up number two again I want to
point out something that we alluded to a
little bit but didn't talk about notice
the spacing between these contours is
very tight and the spacing between these
contours is very open right so if I were
to walk let's say I were to walk
straight across this direction here far
to walk straight across this direction I
would notice that the the pressure as I
move this way is decreasing but not by
much whereas if I walk this direction I
would notice that the air pressure is
decreasing but it's decreasing at a much
more rapid rate okay so we have a name
for this is called pressure gradient
here as I walk along these tightly
spaced contours the pressure is changing
rapidly as I walk right here not so much
we would say this has a high pressure
gradient this has a low pressure
gradient what would the pressure
gradient be like if I walked out through
here well we're not crossing any
contours at all so the pressure gradient
itself is essentially zero so there's
very little to no pressure change in
here so very low pressure gradient or if
I walk through here or swim I guess it
would be across the ocean this way the
pressure is just barely changing right
through here so it's a very low pressure
gradient this is a higher pressure
gradient okay so turns out the wind
speed depends on the pressure gradient
so winds blow faster where the pressure
gradient is stronger so if I had
to shade in say where is the where is
the highest wind speed in this diagram
the highest wind speed are going to be
the locations where the the pressure
contours are closest together so be a
very very high wind speed for example
all around the SLO here where these
pressure contours are very tight what
about out in here out in here the winds
are probably non-existent out here or
the winds are very very slow out in here
so you can use the spacing of the
contours to predict how fast the wind is
going to blow okay so to conclude what
we've learned here just using air
pressure from a barometer we can create
a sea-level pressure map from that map
we can identify places where the air is
rising and sinking from that we can
figure out where it's going to be cloudy
and clear then we can use the contours
to figure out the direction of the wind
and we can use the spacing of the
contours to get a relative sense of wind
speed so all of this is just due to one
thing which is air pressure all right
thanks for listening
you